tant qu'hôte pas cette fois organis
quand même à l'air d'en profiter pour
pour durcir notre notre régime est donné
un précédent dans l'impression que les
croyants duraient des citoyens à
surveiller davantage
alors que le président république
les responsables de cultes le 2 octobre
pour leur annoncer son discours des
mureaux et puis par la même occasion
donc ce projet de loi qui ont des
carnets la suite il nous avait dit que
la philosophie c'était de rendre plus
difficile moins attrayant le régime des
associations de 1901 objets cultuels qui
sont qui le régime privilégié par les
par les musulmans en france pour toutes
sortes de raisons pour les pousser à
aller vers le régime de 1905
parce que les associations cultuelles de
1905 sont plus encadrés plus plus plus
surveillé que donc ça ça permettait à
l'état de ne pas les meilleures
connaissances bon cette philosophie là
vous allez enfin m'allait très bien à
moi comme à tous les autres responsables
de culte
donc le point qui nous embête le plus
c'est l'article 27 qui prévoit que tous
les cinq ans il faut renouveler près du
préfet déclaré de nouveau près du préfet
le caractère cultuel de de notre
association
donc là on est typiquement devant une
disposition qui va un peu nous alourdir
l'existence avec des effets juridiques
qui peuvent être gênant parfois
éventuellement mais surtout on peut
douter de s'inquiéter de l'efficacité de
cette mesure parce que les habitations
qui se voudrait vraiment islamiste ou
séparatiste quelques manières qu'ont les
cons qu'on les comprenne et bien
n'entreront pas dans ce régime et puis
c'est tout donc elles iront en sous
marin
donc nous les protestants les et puis je
dirais même les musulmans bien installé
en france nous le disons mais pourquoi
est-ce que c'est nous qui payons le prix
de la lutte contre contre eux contre les
islamistes
maintenant de fait tempête va cette fois
organisé quand même à l'air d'en
profiter pour pour durcir notre régime
et demander un précédent dans
l'impression que les croyants de
quelques croyances qu'il soit serait des
citoyens à surveiller davantage que que
les autres
au moins je ne veux pas qu'il ya un
fossé entre qui se creuse entre l'église
et les tâches des 15 membres de
catholiques ont peut-être cette
impression est nettement d'avoir
contourné reçues on est reçu une entrée
très courtoisement on est très bien
accueillie très bien écouter on est dans
une année en france dans une situation
qui est que la france n'est plus un pays
majoritairement massivement catholique
dans un pays pluriel on n'a qu'à une
grande population n'a pas une très
grande pratique religieuse quelle quelle
qu'elle soit et même pas chrétienne dans
lequel iliad est en revanche et pratique
musulmane qui est plus forte qui est
croissante parce qu'elle partait de zéro
et donc l'état de plus de mal à
comprendre à connaître suffisamment donc
il le fait avec
ils ont sans doute avec sympathie
admettons mais avec ses instruments à
lui bon l'état c'est l'état donc l'état
il est chargé d'organiser l'ordre public
donc tout ça c'est jamais très d'être
bienveillant mais tout ça c'est toujours
un peu de l'encadrement quand même